Oh David it looks spectacular how did it
go oh well it went pretty well is quite
a success as we speak its rising ever
upwards through space and over the next
two days it will rise three hundred and
ninety three kilometers before docking
with King Kong - which is of course the
Space Lab that they put up there last
month
right I mean how did this work what are
the asteroids got you're going to be
doing once they are of course well into
deep space well the main thing they'll
be doing is popping propaganda a lot of
experiments they're going to be testing
out equipment like the space bicycle
that they've got up there for our
exercise that has some plant they'll
they'll do experiments on as well as
some good book projects there are three
projects from Hong Kong high school
students that I'll be working on
whilst up in space David we know that
this is a source of pride of national
pride when it comes to the Chinese
government I mean what is this signifier
for the Chinese space program well it
signifies an attempt to be the same as
everyone else in many ways and even
better
China unlike Russia is not allowed to
cooperate with NASA for example and so
you know China's responses to
essentially build its own rockets its
own manned Space Agency program and now
it wants to build its own Space Station
eventually they also want to get to Mars
by Iran 2040 so this is all about
proving that China is a superpower in
its own right